ja wie fange ich am besten an mein
Kumpel Daniel aus Berlin ein
retourenhändler der macht viel mit
Retouren Pipapo hat mir letztens
folgende Nachricht geschickt
Neuigkeiten ich hätte gern mal erzählt
von den DHL Retouren und jetzt ist es
soweit dass ich kurz davor stehe im
ganzen LKW voll zu kaufen aber ich
vorher immer mit dir absprechen muss
dann zusammengesetzt weil in dem Fall
ist halt so dass man wirklich einen
ganzen LKW kaufen muss also man kann
nicht nur eine Palette nehmen man muss
alles nehmen Preis für ich glaube 28
Paletten waren ca 22.000 €. ich dachte
mir auch erstmal so okay mache ich das
jetzt aber dann haben wir es gemacht und
ich bin vorgestern nach Berlin gefahren
ich wünsche euch viel Spaß bei diesem
wundervollen Video ja Leute was geht und
hier steht nun ich habe das gerade
wirklich auch zum ersten Mal gesehen bin
erstmal fast hinten rüber gefallen weil
es so viel ist ja wir sind jetzt in
Berlin beim Daniel und das ist gestern
angekommen hast gesagt nee Alter was
haben wir da denn jetzt hier fabriziert
ja Leute hier ist der Daniel und der hat
mir wann hast du mir die Nachricht
geschickt von der Woche ungefähr meinte
so hier guck mal das sind ungefähr
ja so fünf bis siebentausend Pakete
wollen wir die kaufen was denn RTL RTL
DHL und das sind halt alles so Deutsche
Post DHL Pakete und ich dachte mir weil
das gerade so gefragt ist er kommt
scheißegal wir machen das einfach mal
und das haben wir jetzt gemacht und
jetzt ist das Zeug da wir können ja
schon sagen was wir dafür bezahlt haben
also es war schon relativ viel erstmal
eigentlich 22.000 22
Paletten haben wir bezahlt da sind
vermutlich 4000 bis 7000 Pakete drin wir
haben keine Ahnung ich glaube ich habe
auch noch nie für irgendwas so viel Geld
bezahlt ja okay deswegen enttäuscht mich
nicht ich habe jetzt nur auf deine
Expertise vertraut naja auf jeden Fall
bin ich jetzt hier um das mal
auszuschecken ich freue mich habe ja
letztens auch so Amazon secret Packs
gekauft die waren geht so aber trotzdem
lustig interessant ich gehe davon aus
dass sie jetzt auch nicht so die mega
war drin ist weil sonst hätte man
sicherlich 100.000 dafür bezahlt aber
wir schauen mal let's go ich gehe jetzt
mal in DHL Paketen Baden das wollte ich
schon immer mal machen
hast du zufällig was bestellt das hier
ist vom Herrn wilhorn aus fuchswinkel
seine das bei Hannover schöne Grüße an
alle die aus Celle kommen schauen wir
doch mal was der Herr willhorn bestellt
hat oh hier ist so ganz Zettel bei es
ist kein Wollmantel wie beschrieben
sondern eine einfache Fleecejacke völlig
falscher Artikel Ausrufezeichen ist
preislich ein Skandal das steht hier ich
mach die mal auf die fließt ja okay so
der hat ja hier ist ein Reißverschluss
in XL steht mir oder dann lasse ich die
jetzt einfach mal an hier sind auch
Amazon Pakete bei der auch interessant
ich würde sagen ich suche mir jetzt
einfach mal ein paar raus und wir machen
wieder entspannt auf und ich schau mal
dass wir geile Sachen ziehen wobei man
ja keine Ahnung diese Fleecejacke hat
mich jetzt noch nicht überzeugt und hier
haben wir Zalando Frau Heinicke aus
Berlin nur bestellt ich bin gespannt
okay
boah so Leute jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
wir machen jetzt mal ein paar weitere
Stichproben und ich versuche geile
Sachen rauszuziehen ja ich weiß gar
nicht wo ich anfangen soll ne guck mal
hier ist noch was Großes ach ja und das
hier wollte ich auch Auspacken dass sie
irgendwas von Amazonas deutsche Amazonas
das hier gehört übrigens auch noch dazu
ne oh mann Alter hier ist die Skyline
von Köln drauf gefunden auf otto.de
die haben einen Hot Airstyler boah das
Ding ist doch bestimmt gar nicht so
schlecht oder ich habe zwar die Marke
noch nie gesehen aber ich guck mal nach
35 € ist doch schon mal ein guter erster
erfunden wenn ich mit zufrieden was
machen wir damit
verschenken der nächste Kunde das hier
ist ja auch ein Laden der nächste Kunde
der jetzt hier bei Dir rein auf den darf
ich das Schenken okay ich glaube hier
ist irgendwie was für ein Grill drin
meinst du es könnten auch so Sachen drin
sein wie Laptops nein ne Gold nein jetzt
sag mal ehrlich normalerweise wenn man
so große Sachen bestellt du bekommst ja
schon auch immer Listen mit einem
Gesamtwert haben wir ja nicht also das
ist halt alles ein bisschen dubios
gelaufen muss ich auch sagen aber keine
Ahnung wir hatten da irgendwie so Bock
drauf ist halt super schwer sowas in
Deutschland zu bekommen
oder zwei kunsthandbäume da gibt es so
Premium Modelle die Kosten über 100 200
Euro ne aber ich glaube es ist nur Deko
man hat die doch erfunden damit man
nicht überall diese Nadeln hat oder guck
mal also die ersten beiden Pakete haben
sich für uns auf jeden Fall alle mal
gelohnt bin ich mal gespannt es heißt ja
nicht immer nur weil das jetzt ein
autokarton ist das auch was von Otto
drin ist weil die Leute schicken ja viel
zurück und ich kann das ja auch von mir
man nimmt einfach manchmal irgendwelche
Kartons die da so rumfliegen aber erste
Eindruck ist gut bis jetzt ich hätte
wirklich gedacht es ist nur Trash aber
das ist wirklich und gucken wie die
riecht richtig neu das ist genau die
neue Otto x Louis Vuitton Kollektion
Leute ganz neu und sehr gefragt was
kostet so eine Tasche mehr nicht die
schick aus ja ich bin heiß auf weitere
Sachen wie stellt mir eigentlich meine
Mütze sieht das schrecklich aus wie so
ein kleiner Studium oder geht Fett sieht
scheiße aus
warte ich habe da in der Mitte eins
gesehen das sieht geil aus wenn sofort
wieder da boah hier in pinkes Paket das
mache ich jetzt nächstes auf Saliha ist
nicht das gleiche Modell wahrscheinlich
wir können ja mal unsere Theorie sagen
wie das zustande kommt wir denken
irgendwelche großen Kaufhäuser bekommen
Retouren und das beispielsweise ist
jetzt alles von der DHL Deutsche Post
das landet auf einem Haufen und die
Verkaufen von weiter und so ist das
jetzt hier gelandet nur was ich mich
frage ist wie die unterscheiden das
jetzt gar keine Laptops drin sind da
bist du in einem bestimmten Wert gehen
so wir machen weiter wir haben hier
einmal Birkenstock Schuhe sind da Schuhe
drin können auch kann alles Mögliche
drin sein und das nächste Amazon package
das werden jetzt äh ich wollte schon
sagen dass er was für meine Mama wieso
ist denn in diesem Paket dann noch mal
sowas ja ich glaube das ist jetzt will
nicht direkt sagen ich bin enttäuscht
wir noch nicht Jogginghose gar nicht so
verkehrt Marke lifini habe ich noch nie
gehört kennst kennst du die was kostet
sowas
meinst du macht jetzt keinen schlechten
Eindruck genau dann mach mal weiter mit
Amazon ich gehe mal davon aus dass hier
auch irgendwas von Amazon drin ist
ja okay das ist jetzt ist das vielleicht
zum Zaubern
was ist das kannst du einen Baby
reinmachen und dann kannst du damit
wippen für ein Baby oder auch für
Zauberer Hokuspokus ich bin weg okay
ich suche jetzt weiter mal nach großen
Artikeln okay
ich habe mich gerade böse verletzt hier
ist ein Jack Wolfskin Karton das wäre ja
geil sag
eine Fake JBL Box habe ich ja früher
immer auf wish oh Maske getestet würde
ich halt jetzt niemanden empfehlen zu
kaufen aber ja vielleicht so für einen
Zehner kann man nicht meckern ne so hier
haben wir jetzt Jack Wolfskin Schuhe das
wäre doch was vom Gewicht her könnte es
wirklich Schuhe sein
Jogginghose wieder irgendeine
Jogginghose aber von der anderen Marke
so daniel hat auch gute Erfahrung der
sucht jetzt einfach mal hier die
nächsten geilen Pakete raus oh nein DHL
Box ja gut geil
schon wieder so ein Schmutz sieht auf
jeden Fall sehr edel aus
überlegt und du kommst mit so einem Teil
also ich weiß es nicht so ganz was ich
davon halten soll muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen nee das sind super Paket von allen
okay Leute was haben wir hier drin ach
so die müssen das nach packen wenn es
nicht richtig zugemacht ist oder wie
meinst du irgendwas fürs Kinderzimmer
merry christmas
hier muss man jetzt leider sagen wir
sind zur falschen Zeit dran ne weiter
geht's das hat jetzt Daniel rausgesucht
deswegen glaube ich schon Einhorn den
Flamingo ah es ist wahrscheinlich so ein
dekorative oder eine Lampe so was
hässliches gesehen die haben wir
irgendwo Strom man kann ja auch
Batterien rein tun also realistisch
gesehen 50 % ist so eher ein Griff ins
Klo und 50% sind gut ne würde ich jetzt
mal sagen als Zwischenfazit das hier
würde ich jetzt eher Kategorie für
manche ist es schön ja ich bin noch
immer für uns wäre es nicht ich bin auch
was so Retouren angeht irgendwie immer
sehr pessimistisch das Schreiben mir
auch vieles tut mir extrem leid aber
keine Ahnung kann mich dann auch nicht
verstellen hier wird jetzt ein
Leuchteffekt rein bearbeitet
ja 5 Euro 10 Euro wie auch immer ich
setze ja voll auf dieses Paket weil man
macht ja nicht umsonst einfach noch hier
jetzt diese Bänder rum wenn es nichts
wertvoll ist ist oder eigentlich macht
man das nicht one two three and the
number vor das hat man schon in der
Grundschule gelernt und von meiner Mama
immer vom Körper wegschneiden guck mal
das ist noch komplett neu verpackt
ein fritch storage Organizer für den
Kühlschrank die haben sich auf jeden
Fall reichlich Mühe gegeben bei der
Verpackung ah okay
verstehe 10 € 20 € kannst du überhaupt
nicht einschätzen aber komplett neu 100
€, also man muss ja fairerweise sagen
diesen mega Fund oder so einen richtigen
mega Fund habe ich jetzt noch nicht
gemacht oder haben wir noch nicht
gemacht aber das ist dann halt auch
einfach so das ist unrealistisch ist und
wahrscheinlich gut da wird sicherlich
auch irgendwo noch was deutlich
krasseres drin sein aber wir können ja
jetzt schlecht 5000 Pakete aufmachen
irgendwelche Bügel boah ich bin echt am
schwitzen Mann die Frage ist jetzt
natürlich was machen war Daniel mit dem
ganzen Zeug also wir haben ein bisschen
überlegt und wir haben natürlich auch
schon
überlegt bevor wir das bestellt haben
weil ich auch wusste dass viele halt
gerade so danach fragen oder ich wurde
extrem oft nach diesen Amazon Paketen
gefragt erstmal vorweg wenn ich ganz auf
den Kopf gefallen ist ihr könnt sie auch
sehen da sind jetzt nicht so die mega
Geisteskranken Sachen drin aber es ist
ja trotzdem ganz interessant deswegen
haben Daniel und ich einen Shop erstellt
wo wir diese Pakete gebündelt
weiterverkaufen ich glaube in 3er Zehner
und 20er Kombination für ungefähr 6 bis
10 € das Paket das Verschicken da alles
Mitarbeiter verursacht Kosten ist ein
Riesenaufwand überlegt euch das trotzdem
gut ob es sich lohnt sowas für euch zu
bestellen weil wenn man enttäuscht wird
wie gesagt wir haben gar keinen Plan was
da genau drin ist also man kann halt
safe of Pech haben der Shop ist in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt und ja
trotzdem war es auf jeden Fall den Kauf
wert ich weiß auch die letzten fünf
sechs Tage schon ziemlich nervös weil
ich wusste okay Dienstag geht's zu
Daniel was ist da drin Leute vielen Dank
fürs zuschauen wir hoffen es hat euch
gefallen lasst gerne ein Abo da macht
sowas in Zukunft öfter haut rein tschau